hello and welcome to this video playing
zb below
ziplow okay
what's the best move on him i don't know
c4 most people play c6 now
not this guy
i always like to get the double finger
in
knight c6 is uncommon for sure
i don't see a particular way to exploit
that if i go d4 he will
probably take on c4
it's a pretty odd
position
but it looks right yeah let's do this d4
takes knight a3 and now i'm back in book
actually knight a3 is what happened i
keep it simple d4 book
it's a it looks strange but i have to
cover it somewhere
someway and knight d2 was
less convincing because
of
i think a5 actually if i remember
correctly
now against a5 i can actually develop
or here i can develop no because of
here i can develop this is the thing
compared to 92
or do i have something better you have
knight e5 here also right this is
something that has to be taken into
account
yeah let's go 95. yeah
yeah exactly knight e5 because with the
knight on d2
now d4 would hang yeah okay it sometimes
takes a moment
in blitz chess it's a bit a bit a bit of
a time burn if you try to remember your
own book
but it it slowly it hits me
what i what i analyzed
so okay and now i now d5 is attacked
um do we take with the pawn i guess so
and now the resulting position is better
for white the question is how we
play this queen b3 e4
i think i go queen b3 here
looking at the b7 pawn
certainly not a pawn that black wants to
cover
in some way but not quite sure how he
can
sacrifice it reasonably
it does cover it okay it's not a very
gruenfeld
style move but okay bishop f4 rook c1
looks like the
normal way to play
maybe he wants to go bishop h3 but i
just play rook c1 then okay now rook c1
and now what
knight to b5 how does he
handle this then a7 is attacked
and also somehow this looks shaky
taking on h3 taking on c7 there's knight
g4 at the end that doesn't look right
maybe this one
and knight a7 the knight doesn't have
squares right
this is a problem for sure
[Music]
okay pawn takes pawn takes is also bad
okay
[Music]
a bit disappointing really
that i didn't find anything
[Music]
anything good here
i'm fairly certain there was something
good i mean not a win
or something like that but maybe
actually at least extract
some some kind of an advantage
yeah now this is attacked
knight f3 maybe i think someone
takes rook has to move yeah maybe i
should be a little bit quicker
knight b3 bishop b8 is that a thing
at least 92 at least so
probably not
okay wow
is some very ambitious move queen c2
maybe this and queen c2
so that i'm threatening to take and win
the bishop
and then i have time to take c6 and play
b3 for
the grinding advantage
i will take b2 here right
okay i have to check here first this
and b3 okay all that
for for one week born but uh
yeah at least i got this
this one weak pawn
queen to e4
i only have 10 seconds
and the position is for sure nothing
special
i just have a minimal pull
not even that maybe check him
yeah i have to make a draw
okay maybe something something smallish
yeah
was was there but we will have a look
so we go here bishop f5 knight e5
and this this looks really fishy i
should have
something so it takes takes
the engine wants to play f4 e4 just like
go go crush him yeah
maybe queen b3 was too lame
looks yeah yeah this this
makes a lot of sense if we i mean
this is all going backwards yeah
it's a pretty strong center okay but i
went here
queen c8 so c6 is
what i mentioned as the dynamic way to
play this not
covering the pawn but i'm mostly
interested in finding out if i have
something here
it really looks like f3 okay
that was bad then no
yeah i couldn't quite play knight eight
takes a7
it just looked it looked fishy
the knight has no square at all
i mean i saw something like that but i i
simply thought okay
this might not get out but okay queen
queen c2 seems to
at least make sure that it gets out
and then i should take a7 but okay i
it seems like i missed something here
i missed e4 e4 is a good tactic yeah
that's true
e4 m because it takes takes
takes and wins a piece so
after e4 you would have to go to h5 i
guess
and then i've won this really nice tempo
like kicks takes rook t1
queen d1 is also a nice move
now that is a lot better for white also
this
this is very nice here
the queen is just completely offside
here
i play this and this next
okay yeah i was
not unhappy about this let's say that i
can
establish some control i actually made a
mistake i
you know what i thought i thought if i
take
then he can take on b2 but i have c7
i did not see c7 i only spotted this
and now i'm even a pawn down so yeah
i should play c7 i didn't see that move
and that is better for white
yeah at the end of the day he has to
probably do
this and then i get the game
position but with the bishop and knight
added and that is a lot better in
comparison because
the knight is the much better piece here
in this structure
his bishop cannot attack anything and
the knight has this nice
job here of covering d2 so i can easily
now play on the light squares like
queen here and so on and he's not
disturbing me with rook d2 or anything
i only played this move because of the
oversight in the other variation yeah
and here
this is probably still a bit better if
you are super precise but
i couldn't do that
and here it's just it's just totally
equal
rookie one
queen c5 maybe the likelihood of a draw
is still really high
because sometimes even if you win a pawn
you cannot win
okay guys thanks for watching